finding something that lights you up I
think you mentioned this earlier but
like if you don't have something that
you're a little bit scared of or you're
a little bit intimidated about like it's
going to be hard to like wake up at 4 45
in the morning when the covers are warm
and if there is something that you can
find that you're interested in
don't be afraid to go for it signing up
is like the first step and like it
doesn't even have to be a race it could
just be like hey I want to you know try
to go to my local Trail and and run it
you know it starts small but if it is
something like big like
I think do it man like there's so many
people that I see like wait to do
something big and then something gets in
the way or they don't have the health to
do it anymore and like it's cliche and
dumb but like sees the sees the
opportunity sees the moment because you
never know what's going to happen